[Musik]
tauziehen um fußball und co politiker
streiten über das tempo bei der
lockerung von corona vorschriften
neustart mit bedenken hunderttausende
schüler und lehrer gehen morgen erstmals
wieder in die schule und mehr als 10.000
neuinfektionen pro tag in russland
nehmen auch die korona erkrankungen
dramatisch zu
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg sonntag der dritte mai
guten abend und willkommen
vorsichtige schrittweise lockerungen und
dann immer wieder prüfen wie sich die
infektionszahlen entwickeln das ist bis
jetzt die strategie von bund und ländern
ab morgen dürfen friseure
kultureinrichtungen und spielplätze
wieder öffnen
das reicht aber viel nicht die ungeduld
wächst die rufe nach mehr freiheiten
werden immer lauter
frankfurt hat mehr lockdown langsam
jedoch kehrt das leben zurück was ab
morgen wo erlaubt ist entscheiden die
länder nach eigenem ermessen das ist uns
bisher in deutschland gelungen einen
gemeinsamen rahmen zu setzen indem sich
die länder bewegen und aus meiner sicht
ist es weiterhin wichtig diesen
gemeinsamen rahmen einzuhalten in
schrittweise zu erweitern aber immer so
dass kontrolliert vorgegangen wird auch
der bundesgesundheitsminister bleibt
vorsichtig hier entspannen im bericht
aus berlin werden sie bis hierhin
geschafft auch durch abstand halten
durch hygiene dass wir diesen virus
nicht schutzlos ausgeliefert sind wir
haben es geschafft dass wir mittlerweile
fünfmal so viele genesener haben wie
noch akut infizierte aber wir merken
geben das schaffen wir nur durch große
anstrengungen im alltag immer deutlicher
macht sich inzwischen jedoch unmut
bemerkbar
am ersten mai etwa in berlin-kreuzberg
bedenken gegen die einschränkung von
grundrechten kommen aber auch von den
liberalen die gewährung von grundrechten
des kein gnadenakt dass eine
verpflichtung und ich bin völlig
entsetzt darüber dass der
kanzleramtsminister häuser brauchen
erklärt er kritisiere gerichte dafür
dass sie die erhaltung der grundrechte
einfordern würden das ist ihre aufgabe
fußballspiele denkbar sagt der
innenminister wenn auch ohne publikum
und mit strengen hygiene auflagen eine
öffnung der grenzen jedoch beurteilt
seehofers skeptisch andere auch
unionspolitiker widersprechen
wir müssen eng koordiniert mit unseren
nachbarn vorgehen mit gut abgestimmten
regeln aber wir brauchen keine grenzen
wir brauchen keine schlagbäume
entscheidungen wie es weitergeht fallen
nächste woche mittwoch beraten merkel
und die ministerpräsidenten der ton der
debatte aber
dringender für schüler gilt unter
strengen auflagen darf ein kleiner teil
von ihnen nämlich die abschlussklassen
wieder in die schule in einigen
bundesländern schon etwas länger in
anderen ab morgen doch auch hier gibt es
zwei sichtweisen zeit wird sagen die
einen zu schnell und zu gefährlich
warnen die anderen orte ferber berichtet
leandro stecken mitten in den
abiturvorbereitungen und er wohnt mit
seiner 94 jährigen oma unter einem dach
anderes schulbesuch ist wichtig klar
aber die gesundheit der oma genauso
familie hessler ist besorgt mir kann
keiner sagen ob jemand in der schule
infektiös ist oder nicht weil es wird
kein test gemacht alle kinder gehen
ungetestet in die schule auch für die
lehrer ja an diesem gymnasium in
dormagen musste der unterricht wegen
einer corona infektion in der familie
eines schülers schon wieder eingestellt
werden
nordrhein westfalens schulministerin
bestätigt es seien sieben der knapp 2000
geöffneten schulen von solchen fällen
betroffen es gibt kritik von einer guten
vorbereitung kann nicht die rede sein
kollegen kollegen vor ort fühlen sich
allein gelassen
ein dilemma die einen demonstrieren für
eine schnelle schuleröffnung andere
fürchten sie lehrerin heike kampling ist
60 jahre alt und vor erkrankt sie
bereitet jetzt unterricht für die
viertklässler vor die zurück in die
schule sollen die kinder werden in
kleinere gruppen aufgeteilt weil ja auch
nicht so viele kinder in einen klassen
haben sollen das haben wir auch alles
schon geplant aber ich selber tauche
eben als klassenlehrerin dann nicht auf
ihre viertklässler werden ohne die
vertraute lehrerin den unterricht
beginnen müssen aber mit viel abstand
und neuen regeln schauen wir auch heute
auf die aktuellen corona zahlen laut
johns hopkins universität sind in
deutschland rund 165.000 infizierte
durch tests bestätigt davon geld mehr
als 130.000 betroffene als genesen 6812
menschen sind in verwendung mit dem
virus gestorben
die zahl der neuinfektionen sei
gestern liegt bei 7 170 während bei uns
die zahl der neuinfektionen sinkt steigt
sie in russland massiv an gestern
erstmals an einem tag auf über 10.000
besonders betroffen die elf millionen
metropole moskau
hier ist die zahl der infizierten am
höchsten die behörden beteuern dass
alles getan wird um die kranken zu
versorgen doch ärzte berichten von
fehlender sicherheitsausrüstung aus
moskau christian sind es werden immer
mehr immer mehr infizierte vor allem in
moskau
die hauptstadt ist der hotspot der
korona epidemie in russland und immer
wieder berichten ärzte über mängel im
system vor allem über schlechte oder
fehlende schutzausrüstung bekommen
beschwerden aus allen regionen und
versucht irgendwie die ausstattung zu
besorgen
es werden anzüge gekauft und geliefert
aber das problem bleibt das ist eine
folge des zerstörten gesundheitssystems
in russland moskaus bürgermeister
sobjanin russlands corona krisenmanager
sagt die hauptstadt habe den höhepunkt
noch nicht erreicht
womöglich könnten sogar mehr als 250.000
menschen infiziert seien
insgesamt gebe es mehr corona fälle weil
mittlerweile mehr getestet werde heißt
es
die ausbreitung des virus wird natürlich
hauptsächlich von denen verursacht dies
haben ohne symptome
es ist also gut wenn die infektion in
einem frühen stadium erkannt wird seit
mehr als vier wochen gilt in moskau
eigentlich eine strenge ausgangssperre
eigentlich einige hält es nicht mehr in
ihren wohnungen
der frühling ist da und auch in moskau
werden die menschen langsam ungeduldig
doch ob die maßnahmen hier bald
gelockert werden können hängt natürlich
sehr von der weiteren entwicklung der
zahlen ab und vom verhalten der menschen
und der moskauer bürgermeister warnt
sollten sich die leute nicht an die
ausgangsbedingungen halten jetzt während
der feiertage könnten die maßnahmen auch
noch mal verlängert oder verschärft
werden
präsident putin regiert im moment nur
noch abgeschottet perry
ministerpräsidenten schuss team hatte
ihn am donnerstag informiert dass er und
corona erkrankt
der kampf gegen das virus ist in
russland noch lange nicht vorbei
die neuesten entwicklungen zur corona
pandemie im ausland und natürlich auch
im inland können sie in unserer zdf
heute app verfolgen mit dem live-blog
bleiben sie jederzeit auf dem laufenden
kann ministerpräsident netanjahu trotz
korruptionsanklage erneut israelischer
regierungschef werden
darüber verhandelt ab heute das höchste
gericht des landes regierungsgegner
hatten eine entsprechende petition
eingebracht
vor knapp zwei wochen hatte sich
netanjahu mit seinem ehemaligen rivalen
ganz auf die bildung einer regierung
geeinigt vor dem parlament versammelten
sich demonstranten die die beratungen
des gerichts auf einer leinwand
verfolgten
es gibt neue details zum angriff auf das
kamerateam des zdf heute show in berlin
so seien laut polizei etwa 15 personen
gemeinsam auf das team losgegangen
mehrere verdächtige stammten aus dem
politisch linken spektrum
sechs der mutmaßlichen angreifer waren
vorübergehend festgenommen worden
bei der attacke vorgestern hatten vier
kollegen verletzungen erlitten
heute vor 75 jahren befreiten britische
soldaten das kz neuengamme in hamburg
mehr als 100.000 menschen aus ganz
europa waren hier den qualen der nazis
ausgesetzt 42.600 häftlinge starben
eigentlich war heute eine internationale
gedenkfeier geplant doch die korona
pandemie hat das verhindert
christina hansen es war ein sehr stilles
gedenken heute in ganz kleinem kreis
ohne überlebende wegen der korona
pandemie konnte niemand anreisen
zehntausende menschen aus den von
deutschland besetzten gebieten waren
hier und in den außenlagern des kz
untergebracht und der schlimmsten
bedingungen mussten sie für die
kriegswirtschaft schuften
wir wurden wie sklaven in viehwaggons
dahin gebracht und dort dann wie sklaven
gehalten
mein vater wurde mir genommen seine
asche ist im gelände verstreut worden
damit keine spur von ihm
als englische truppen nach neuengamme
kommen sind die baracken leer
die ss hatte das lager aufgelöst
tausende häftlinge wurden an die ostsee
auf schiffe wie die kap arkona gebracht
am dritten mai bombardierten englische
flugzeuge die schiffe weil sie deutsche
truppen an bord vermuteten
ich bin ein überlebender der kap arkona
fast 7000 menschen aber mussten sterben
es ist so unendlich tragisch dass sie so
kurz vor der befreiung noch einen so
schrecklichen tod sterben mussten
hamburgs erster bürgermeister peter
tschentscher betonte wie wichtig es sei
auch nach 75 jahren immer wieder an das
grauen zu erinnern wir wissen dass
populismus antisemitismus und
ausgrenzung fremdenfeindlichkeit wenn
man nicht acht gibt zu solchen
entwicklungen führen die für heute
geplante größere gedenkfeier will man
nächstes jahr nachholen dann mit den
noch wenigen überlebenden eine der
überlebenden von neuengamme hedi fried
sagte in ihrer videobotschaft ich habe
vertrauen in das deutschland von heute
das gute werde immer über das schlechte
siegen ja noch das wetter morgen gibt es
in der mitte und im süden viele wolken
und einige schauer im südosten auch
gewitter im norden ist es freundlich auf
den nordseeinseln werden elf grad
erreicht am oberrhein 23 grad
am dienstag gibt es noch schauer ab
mittwoch scheint überall die sonne
um viertel vor zehn christian sievers
mit dem heute-journal ihnen alles gut